okay so our next speaker is I think
Butler let me just make sure yes Butler
Lamson also from our lab and he will
talk about unusable security
oops well I was going to talk about a
new little security but I changed my
mind day before yesterday and I'm going
to talk about retroactive security
instead so what could that possibly mean
why would you want security to be
retroactive well the classic way to do
security is so-called access control and
we've been trying it for 40 years and
basically it doesn't work and there's
two reasons for that one is bugs which
I'll talk about later and the other is
that the job of access control is to say
no and when you're trying to get your
job done you don't want the system to
say no so the tendency is for the system
to evolve towards saying yes and thus
being less secure the other reason
second reason why retroactive security
makes sense is real world security is
retroactive the reason that burglars
don't break into my house is not that
they can't get through the lock on the
front door or break through a window of
course they can it's book because
although the risk of being caught and
sent to jail is small it's big enough to
make the whole proposition and economic
similarly the security the financial
system doesn't actually depend on vaults
and encryption and all that stuff it
depends on the fact that almost
everything in the financial system can
be undone the third reason why you want
to do things retro actively is that the
best is the enemy of the good people
have had this dream that we understand
exactly how computers work and therefore
should be able to build systems that are
perfectly secure and we've been trying
to do that for 40 or 50 years and what
we've learned is that you can only do it
for very small very bounded
self-contained systems which are
typically not the kind of systems that
we want just a brief word about access
control the classic way of doing things
the idea is the model for access control
is you have some resource that you're
trying to protect you wrap it in
isolation boundary or when requests come
in from the outside to do things they
pass through a guard whose job it is to
decide whether or not the request should
be granted that's the classic way of
doing business so what about how does a
retroactive security work by contrast
what about blame how do you attribute
blame when something goes wrong roughly
speaking the idea is you use the access
control ideas
only to keep out people that you can't
punish everything else you deal with by
punishing this limits behaving person
how does that work well you make some
common-sense rules you let the
individuals override the machines blind
enforcement of what of its version of
the common-sense rules but you do log
all the accesses every time somebody
does something read or write you log who
did it and what it was that was done if
you notice problems then you use the log
to find the culprits in addition you can
mine the log looking for unusual
behavior especially cases where the some
user decided to override the machines
interpretation of the rules to make this
work you do need good authentication so
that you know who took the actions and
you also need an audit log which is
reasonably easy to to look at and to
study which is not something that we
typically actually have what about
integrity people worry a lot about
probably in fact probably the thing that
people worry about most in security is
that their data might get corrupted the
retroactive way to approach this problem
is selectively undo what's the idea here
you log all the state changes their
inputs in their outputs and if your
system gets corrupted you fix it by
resetting it to some old state that you
think is good installing patches
blocking known attacks that were made on
the system since that point and then you
reply all the logged actions except the
blocked ones and you might think that
isn't going to work because it's going
to take too long to replay all the
actions however most of the actions are
going to have the property that um their
inputs are unchanged and the actual code
of the action is unchanged and therefore
the outputs are going to be unchanged so
you don't actually have to replay the
action you can just take the output from
the log of course this doesn't always
work but it works amazingly often in
practice sometimes it needs user input
to resolve the conflicts if it needs too
much user input then it collapses under
its own weight but it's quite surprising
that on a very large fraction of the
time it it can work without any user
assistance what about secrecy now here
the idea is a little bit more subtle we
want to be able to undo publication how
can you stop the internet from
remembering your nude photo forever so
here the idea is when you post something
you tag it as yours and well-behaved
applications and services like Google
and Facebook and outlook and so forth
will respect the tags what does it mean
to respect the tag first of all it means
that whenever you copy the data around
you copy the tag with it and secondly it
means that whenever you do anything with
the data you consult the current policy
for the tag that means you go to some
website with which is associated with
the tag and you see what the current
rules are for dealing with that data and
modules can change if it's my data I
establish the policy I can go in there
and say I don't want anyone to see that
nude photo anymore so that's the way you
take take it back now of course if
someone has copied the nude photo onto
their own hard drive and remove the tag
then they're not being well behaved and
there's nothing the system can do about
that so it doesn't solve all the world's
problems but it does mean that that
information is not going to be out there
on google or facebook or manipulated by
office or other or Photoshop or other
well-behaved applications which is not
perfect but it makes things much better
than they are now what about bugs as I
mentioned earlier one of the big
problems with access control is that
there are bugs and if the axe and any
bug can make trouble for the access
control and since its access control is
a prospective way of doing things that's
fatal and our experience tells us that
except for very small and very narrowly
defined systems we always have bugs that
subvert the access control so we have to
remember real world security is not
about locks it's about deterrence the
problem we have today is that on the net
you can't find the bad guys so you can't
deter them so what's the fix for that
the fix is refuse inputs that are not
accountable enough if a man into your
system from some
quite a place that you can't punish you
should throw it on the floor that will
prove prevent it from tickling a bug and
what what's the meaning of
accountability accountability mean
someone is accountable if you can punish
them punished but it doesn't necessarily
mean you're going to send them to jail
it might mean that you're going to
they're going to be fined or they're an
employee who's going to be disciplined
or fired or they're a friend whom you're
going to ostracise or whatever the basic
notion here is you get to decide well
what constitutes a sufficient amount of
accountability I and balance that again
against what you think is the value of
the information that you're protecting
the obvious problem with this
accountability idea is if I want to
browse the internet freely there's a lot
of stuff out there then I'm going to
look at that's not particularly
accountable so how can we deal with that
the answer to that is sort of obvious
now you divide the world into two parts
a green part which contain stuff that
you care about and a red part which you
can think of as a playground where you
live wild and free in the green part you
demand accountability so for example if
you're very conservative and you say my
green part is only for my financial
transactions then the only things I'm
going to be I'm going to do on the green
part are to talk to my own bank the red
part i can talk to anybody if it runs
into trouble you just push the reset
button and that's okay because it
doesn't have anything in it that's
important to you so to sum this up
access control hasn't worked we should
learn from the way real world security
works which is retro actively we should
do auditing we should have selective
undo we should establish ownership of
data that's published on the internet
and for bugs we should have
accountability thank you hey thank you
well this sort of okay to talk and we
have time for a few questions surely
there are questions or anguish
complaints or something
honey and so I just want to ask you what
happens in the auditing if you have a
spiracy an interaction among many bad
things that happened how hard is it to
find that interaction rather than one
bad thing that happened well it can be
quite difficult I don't know if you know
the story of the Stuxnet virus that
attacked the Iranians and uranium
separating centrifuges that was about
six bad things had to happen in order to
get them into trouble so it can be
difficult life is hard it's not as
though it's I'm it's not as though
either this approach is going to be
perfect or the car where of doing things
is so wonderful that we shouldn't try to
improve it any more questions
okay then let's sync upload again hey
our next